but unfortunately for dari  well  the queen on a1 is standing black has  the pawn up  and the a pawn will queen most likely  because  nobody can stop that spawn i believe  north korea nor  anybody else would not be possible  there's no sensible queen  check for white  wow richard  what a game  oh yeah it was  completely unexpected of course that i  uh converted this plus the whole game  was like you know  uh very concrete and  always depending on  but the pressure i mean you had the  pressure  yeah it felt like that you know but  of course i could be wrong yeah i mean  it's really a concrete position and he  has this um  threats basically just to go around  there  so yeah i thought this bishop hd was  very clever  yeah we were thinking that